مئات الشهداء الفلسطينيين في اكبر مجزره
تنفذها اسرائيل في غزه لم يكن المكان ساحه
حرب بل هو مستشفى المعمداني الذي لاذ به
النازحون من القصف يظنونه امنا وفق
القانون الدولي الانساني لكن اسرائيل لا
رادع لها اذ تقتل ولا زاجر لها وهي تسفك
الدم الفلسطيني ليل
نهار الها وهي تبيد شعبا بنسائه واطفاله
لا احد فاسرائيل منذ البدايه قررت ان تنزع
عن الفلسطيني في غزه انسانيته فلم ترى اهل
غزه الا حيوانات لا يثير قتلها حساسيه ولا
يرتقي الى رؤيته جريمه في حق احد فالعالم
الغربي النادب نفسه لحراسه حقوق الانسان
وقيمه في الدنيا لا يسائل عن الضحايا بل
يدير وجهه عنه
متخفيا وراء عباره من حق اسرائيل ان تدافع
عن نفسها لقد منحت الدول العظمى اسرائيل
اذنا بالقتل لا احتراز فيه ولا زاجر يقيد
يدها عن سفك دماء المدنيين فقد تواط
العالم على استباحه الدم الفلسطيني تخوض
فيه اسرائيل في حرب لا تكافؤ فيها ولا
مواجهه بين جند وجند بل هو القصف العشوائي
يقتل حيث
يقتل ستوي عند الطيار الاسرائيلي كل
الاماكن فلا فرق بين بنايه تضم المئات من
المدنيين ممن لا يحملون السلاح وبين
مستشفى هو في اخلاق الحرب وقوانينها ارض
حرام لكن اسرائيل لا تعير القوانين حساب
وقد ضمن التاييد العالمي لها وهي تتقمص
دور الضحيه المستدرك للشفقه والتعاطف قبل
المجزره التي وقعت جراء قصف مستشفى
المعمداني كانت اسرا قد قتلت نحو 3 الا
فلسطيني واصابت اكثر من 100 الا فما ردعها
رادع ولا نها هناه الا بالطف العبارات
التي كانها تقول اما اتفيت بعد مجزره
المعمداني تقول ان اسرائيل ما اشتفت بعد
من جراء ما لحق بعسكر تها واستخبارات من
ضربه موجعه اورثها تعطش للدم لا ينتهي
ولكن هب ان الغرب طوا مع اسرائيل فما
بالوا اصحاب القضيه المركزيه وقد سكتوا
الا عن الادانات
العاجزه تقع المجزره الاسرائيليه في غزه
فتقتل وتصيب اكثر من الف في ساعه واحده
يحدث ذلك وغزه واسرائيل يحيط بهما مئات
الملايين من العرب انها الكثره العاطله ما
تغني سيتحمل الفلسطيني مسؤوليه حياته
وخياراته وهو يتحرك مقاتلا او مواطنا بين
خياري الشهاده او النصر سيتحمل الصامتون
الخاذل غزه وهي تعيش تحت القصف والحصار
مشقه حياتهم المتارجح بين عجز هو والموت
سيان وبين حياه تكبل الاغلال في الايد
والاقدام تحس ولا ترى قد يكون الضعف في
المحيطين العربي والاسلامي هو الذي اغرى
اسرائيل قتل وارتكاب المجازر في غزه اما
مجزره مستشفى المعمداني على وجه التحديد
فهي تماد في سفك الدم شجع عليه علم
اسرائيل ان شيء في العالم العربي
والاسلامي غير اجرار الكلام القديم غزه
ومقاومتها نزعت الاقنعه عن
الجميع الشارع العربي وحده الذي ما اكثر
محيل بينه وبين الفعل يظل دالا على ان
اليه تقع في مكان اخر هو افئده الشعوب لا
البيانات راتبه او
طارئه